ich kann mich das buch wieder öffne rein
theoretisch mit das wetter auf rain
machen dann kann ich mir sagen okay ich
möchte jetzt aber doch gerne in den
spectator mode gehen damit spectator
mord jetzt fängt an zu regnen damit kann
ich quasi alles bestimmen in minecraft
küche meiner lieben freund und herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge
minecraft commands was ich sehr viele
leute gewünscht hatten und deswegen
mache ich jetzt und ich würde mich
freuen wenn er bis zum ende dran bleibt
und ja der erste command wurde mir
zugesendet von basti tee und zwar
beschreibt er sein command als riesige
explosion
dafür eigentlich gar nicht diesen
command blog ich setze jetzt da trotzdem
mal erfolg erzielt inventur stark es
geht den command aber mal lieber hier
vorne beispielsweise ein und zwar machte
zusammen ender chris und ich schon hier
ist ein ender kristall und das ist ihr
die pferdeturm ihr eigentlich schon
extrem leid und zwar das ist dieser
ändert christa linie in ende seht woran
sich der ender drache quasi immer so
seiner energie bemüht also der fit
halten und legt sich dann wieder auf bzw
das ist so seine macht quelle und wenn
wir das ganze oft eingeben
so ich habe das jetzt mega oft
eingegeben und ihr seht schon hier ist
ein riesiges irgendwas und das lied
auswählen soll transformers und wenn ich
schlage wahrscheinlich aus dem ende
musste teile zerstören damit der ender
drache dann sollen seine macht nicht
mehr hatte und danach kann man erste
länder drachen zerstören die machen
keine riesen explosion also es heißt
nicht desto mehr ändern kristall ich
mache so wie bei dem dnt desto größer
ist der komplette explosions radius nie
aber desto höher fliege ich in die luft
und wenn wir das ganze mal rein
theoretisch noch mal machen können wir
mal obst obst ich bin ja schon bei den
ganzen befehlen hier die ich hier
forschen eingeben habe wir können das
ganze theoretisch einfach nochmal machen
damit ihr dann seht da können wir
eigentlich schon ganz schön hoch fliegen
wollen ich glaube das wird nicht gut
enden aber ich schlage jetzt einfach mal
guten tag mal dass der mond da ist die
sonne dass der mond die sonne und ich
denke weil ich überhaupt ja ich falle
aber ich war irgendwie in 2000 metern
höhe und jetzt werde ich kann damit auf
jeden fall mega witzige sachen anstellen
und ich hab gerade überhaupt keinen plan
wo ich bin das hier sitzt übrigens erst
mal so die romands welt für diese der
erste zweite wo bin ich wo war das denn
wo habe ich das denn in die luft
gesprengt man das sieht schon mal sehr
sehr okay da vorne war dass ich denke ja
guck mal das ist echt oder wurde jetzt
überhaupt irgend explosion ist überhaupt
stattgefunden
ihr seht mal er hat einfach nur diese
radius um sprechende daten hat zunächst
passiert aber ich bin trotzdem 2000 die
nächste sache wurde mir zugesendet von
snippy zog und zwar endlich ein
richtiges flug verpasst was ich euch
erst gezeigt hatte in der letzten folge
mit diesem hühnchen ist ja nur unter
gekleidet aber man kann das gleiche auch
mit einer fledermaus machen
und jetzt kann ich mich an was ich muss
ich muss er hat mir das nämlich so
geschickt aber ich muss bett großmann
vertippt und jetzt kann ich hier mit
rechtskreisen setzen und ihr seht schon
ich bin jetzt einem flugzeug und canet
mit jetzt quasi rumfliegen das ist jetzt
nicht so langweilig wie mit seinem
schicken das was schicken einfach
untergeht sondern das delikt in alle
richtungen rein theoretisch könnte man
das ganze noch mit beim pendler drachen
noch machen ich hätte halt ehrlich
gesagt keinen bock das jetzt mal eine
ganze welt kaputt macht aber das ist so
eine art flugzeug und das wäre extrem
cool vor allem wenn man was ich mir mal
gedacht hat wenn man die fledermaus
sowie ein schwein mit seinen roten
carroll denkt man damit quasi einfach
auch das für die fledermaus machen
könnte dann hängt man da dann irgendwie
hasen dran oder firmen die angel oder
anhängig die jetzt nur nach vorne dann
wird die fledermaus genau in die
richtung fliegen
das wäre extrem cool und damit wird
dieses flugzeug war sie noch mehr sinn
ergeben sagt ich mal wieder luft welchem
creative not bin finde ich extrem cool
wurde mir zugesendet von isny bezog und
wir kommen jetzt auch schon direkt zu
command nummer drei und jetzt die
fledermaus xe ist extrem stark dafür
dass er versonnen mein geld auf den kopf
dreht die dritte sache wurde mir von
extrem vielen leuten zu besonders über
das commands formular das findet ihr
übrigens wenn ihr auch command
irgendwelche coolen command findet ihr
in der beschreibung in dem ersten link
oder so über den link für mein mikro
findet ihr glaube ich ein formular da
könnt ihr draufklicken und da könnt ihr
müsst ihr anwalt oder irgendwie sowas da
könnt ihr mir auch ein command hin seien
mit beschreibungen so dass es extrem
cool ingolstadt voll bauchschmerzen ende
das wenn ihr so richtige bauch nicht
schmerzen noch richtige krämpfe habt
alles so kritisch wie so als wäre da
drin was und damit einfach so machen
sich mut ihre in diesem video noch zu
einem zombie aber naja konzentriert wird
sie doch die command also wir müssen das
eingeben
und jetzt einen extrem langen befehl der
volt mir zugesendet von ganz ganz viele
leute haben ja schon gesagt die meisten
wollen anonym bleiben weil sie denken
nicht dass er uns erwähnt ist es geklaut
sagt irgendwer
jetzt habe ich aus versehen want to
check jetzt habe ich hier die ganze
scheiße und ein gefühl ein moment sollte
ich habe jetzt den passenden command und
zwar ihr findet ihn link dazu einer
beschreibung dann könnt ihr euch selber
kopieren ich habe nicht den ganzen
commander die beschreibung gepackt weil
viele command und außerdem wer hier geht
über 100 zeilen und
wenn meine ganze beschreibung kaputt
gehen wir nicht so was da ein paket an
jahre laden dauern die zu öffnen
jedenfalls ist dass der ganze komplex
100 zeilen lang oder so klick auf fertig
mache ich also nicht bekomme ein
magisches buch und wenn ich dieses buch
öffne
seht ihr hab ich hier alle sachen drin
ich kann hier mit in den survival mode
gehen
ich kann mich das buch wieder öffne rein
theoretisch mit das wetter auf rain
machen dann kann ich mir sagen okay ich
möchte jetzt aber doch gerne in den
spectator mode gehen damit spectator
mord jetzt fängt es an zu regnen damit
kann ich quasi alles bestimmen minecraft
jetzt denk ich mir komm mach ich jetzt
mal aus dann mache ich jetzt mal die
schwierigkeit auf normal
dann kann ich hier mal auf die seite
gehen command feedback aus ich könnte
rein theoretisch die mobs bei uns
ausmachen regeneration briefing ist auch
extrem cool also damit keine explosion
kommen und so richtig geil danke an euch
als community dass er sowas mitgeteilt
habe ich weiß das gibt es halt schon
vorher auf einer website mit command ist
es halt so eine sache
die gibt's irgendwo schon mal sonst
hätte die niemand denkt sich elendig
lange commanders also das ist nicht
schlimm dass man in welchen webseiten
ebenfalls haben wir auch echt viele
geschrieben sie haben noch nirgendwo auf
youtube eine serie gesehen war einfach
so witzige commands vorgestellt werden
so wirklich als serie finde ich extrem
cool wie sehr doch noch nicht gesehen
aber das war kummer nummer drei nächste
sache wurde mir zugesendet von jonas
foster mann und zwar schreibt der mann
behält sein item will man steht uns war
es dass dieser kommt das ist gameplay
schrägstrich game room leerzeichen keep
inventory leerzeichen troubadour falls
macht dann wenn ihr sterbt habt ihr eure
sachen haben auch nicht mehr
aber wenn ich das noch zusätzlich habe
ich zum beispiel jetzt bei den experten
und command welten sagt diese teams
setzten inventar ein gras einen allein
gras block 1 grasen schafe
jetzt mache ich mit skill töte ich gehe
auf wieder blieben und ich hab die items
immer noch im inventar also dass es
extrem cool wenn ihr in seiner bauwelt
seiten ihr sterbt gegen die aus versehen
und seitdem creative oder wenn ihr im
survival mode sei da könnt ihr das
natürlich auch machen und wenn ihr
sterbt ich möchte trotzdem eure sachen
noch behalten könnte das damit ganz
locker aktivieren ist ein ganz ganz
simpler command aber ich denke viele
kannten jedoch nicht und dass man also
dementsprechend einstellen kann
mit diesem command und ich finde es
extrem cool also danke an dich jonas für
diesen vierten command ich muss sagen
meine lieben freunde dieser fünfter
command ist extrem kurz aber extrem
sich und zwar gibt man einfach ein slate
ep teleport also at alle entities auf
dieser welt oder zumindest im umkreis
hier also zu mir teleportieren und wenn
ich das mal drücke kommen alle mops zu
mir wir sehen hier extrem viele
tintenfische ganz viele schweine schafe
wir sehen mops die am verrecken sind wir
den hexen wir sehen hier auch in welche
pferde alles mögliche ist es einfach so
witzig wir sehen hier auch güter
ok ich glaube 8
diese sachen hier werden ja auch aus dem
einchecken ja auch als entities
angesehen loben weil man mit denen ihr
interagieren kann genauso wie mit
rüstung schneller okay stimmt das ist
echt cool das ist richtig graz gerade
also mit diesem command kann ich alle
motto mir teleportiert rein theoretisch
könnte ich auch mal einfach nach oben
fliegen könnte das jetzt machen und
sorry ich ist ein extrem cooler command
und auch ich meine viele sind zwar schon
tot aber ich ganz trotz machen weil auch
schon wieder exzellente neue gesten sind
jetzt gar nicht mehr so nach und es
kommen falls sie mal wieder neue dazu
kelterfest richtig witzig man kann mit
diesem ob sie spielen wie man will jetzt
in diesmal wieder alle tot sind schon
wieder neue gefahren bin ich richtig
witzig und das war commander 5 wenn es
euch gefallen hat und ich euch
unterhalten konnte würde ich mich sehr
über eine positive bewertung freuen wenn
ihr irgendwelche commands kennt wo ihr
denkt da die verschwender die man den
chat video zeigen würde
unten irgendwo in den ersten reihe
zahlen ist ein link commands formular
doppelpunkt in so einem kurzen keine
draufklicken könnt mir die da einfach
rein schreiben und das ist dann euro
chance eventuell im nächsten video mit
dabei zu sein und sonst würd ich sagen
simons an am nächsten kurs video wieder
tschüss